back to DC
r it would you recommend to other actors
that they write a powerful role for
themselves especially a woman these days
in Hollywood and heavy you came into
your own as an actor later because you
found out kind of who you were can you
advise other actors to find out what
their style is some of so many of us
want to be a certain disorder but you
were willing to wait and sort of come
into your own or just took right no rich
but I certainly do now know who I am NOT
and I that helps me it's help me guide
me in my decisions and figure out where
I want to be in what I want to do it is
extraordinary business beautiful thank
you and enjoy your night